it takes a lot of hard work and good
luck to get a movie made but all of that
can be ruined in an instant with just
one bad decision the Masterwork of
horror and science fiction author HP
Lovecraft at the mountains of madness
has long been a passion project for
horror artour guo Del Toro and Del Toro
seems like the perfect fit for the tale
of a group of scientists who discover
ancient terrifyingly powerful entities
in Antarctica unfortunately despite
James Cameron producing an interest from
Tom Cruz Del Toro couldn't get funding
from Universal because he told them it
would be R-rated meaning the teens who
usually flock to horror movies wouldn't
be able to see it the project was
cancelled and Del Toro later said he
should have lied to Executives and told
them that at the mountains of Madness
would be
PG13 there were a lot of dumb decisions
that led to the demise of the proposed
Halo movie Mostly because Microsoft
apparently had no idea how Hollywood
Works they demanded a huge cut of
profits and forced Studios to jump
through hoops to even have a chance to
read the script plus they wouldn't let
Sony bid on the film at all because
Sony's Playstation is one of Microsoft
Xbox's Chief video game console
competitors despite all that nonsense
Fox and Universal were both still
interested and teamed up but then they
made the final dumb decision in this
whole dumb process when Universal hired
up-and-comer Neil Blum Camp to direct
Blum Camp was a fan of the game with a
distinct artistic Vision the problem is
only Universal wanted him both Fox and
Microsoft reportedly hated what he was
doing wanting instead to make what the
director called a generic boring film
something like gi. Joe or some crap like
that ultimately the only thing that came
of it was some test footage that teases
the great Halo movie that could have
been and Blum Camp he went on to make
District 9 instead great job
Microsoft in 1968 Richard prior wrote
and starred in an extremely dark
socially conscious movie with the
intentionally controversial title Uncle
Tom's fairy tales the movie for
homosexuals prior supposedly became so
obsessed with making the film his wife
reportedly destroyed the negative of the
then still unfinished movie in a fit of
rage nearly four decades later another
print of the film emerged thanks to
director Penelope spus but so far it
hasn't been released either based on G
de's intense graphic novel about the
struggles of living under the
totalitarian regime in North Korea
pongyang was supposed to start shooting
an early 2015 with Steve Carell in the
lead role and gorer binsky as director
then Sony decided to release the
interview in 2014 that reportedly led to
the infamous hack of the Sony servers in
retaliation not to mention bomb threats
against theaters that screen the
interview new Regency decided pongyang
wasn't worth the hassle and canell the
film
entirely JRR Tokens The Lord of the
Rings books rank among the most beloved
novels of all time first published is
three separate volumes in 195 54 it took
until 2001 for Peter Jackson's epic
liveaction adaptation to hit movie
theaters but there was an earlier
version proposed in the 1960s and it
would have starred The Beatles yeah
those Beatles besides doing a brand new
double album soundtrack The Beatles were
set to star in the liveaction adaptation
with Paul McCartney as froto Ringo Star
as Sam wise George Harrison is Gandalf
and John linnen is Gollum and
fortunately tolken wasn't a Beatles fan
and he decided to Nix the idea otherwise
both music and cinematic history would
have been completely different and much
much weirder Star Trek was cancelled
after three seasons in 1969 but its
popularity exploded in syndicated reruns
by 1977 the series was set to hit the
big screen with a film called Star Trek
planet of the Titans where the
Enterprise and Captain Kirk would face
off against the Giants of Greek
mythology but just before filming was
set to begin Paramount president Barry
Diller canceled the whole thing for a
really stupid reason Star Wars was
already scheduled to arrive in theaters
that year and he didn't think fans could
like sci-fi enough to support two space
epics in the same year uh where to
totally completely misread the entire
industry
[Music]
Barry long before Marvel crushed the box
office with Avengers Warner Brothers was
planning its own superhero team up in
the form of Justice League mortal which
went into production in 2007 with Mad
Max Fury Road director George Miller
said to direct the film had a budget of
$200 million and had already begun
rehearsing with a cast that included
Army Hammer as Batman Megan Gail as
Wonder Woman and the rapper Common as
Green Lantern just one problem they
forgot to actually finish writing the
script and before they could get around
to it The Writers Guild of America went
on strike by the time the strike ended
the actors had moved on to other
projects and the whole film had to be
scrapped
whoops in 2008 Pixar announced its later
films for the coming years and among
them was a movie called n the plot what
happens when the last remaining male and
female Blue-footed NES on the planet are
forced together by science to save the
species and they can't stand each other
it was so far along in production that
Pixar animators left little Easter egg
referencing new in Toy Story 3 such as
the N crossing sign on Andy's bedroom
door but in 2011 Animation Studios
released Rio which had almost the exact
same plot only with birds instead of
lizards and which had reportedly been in
production since around 2007 one year
before new was announced Pixar panicked
worried that n would be considered a
ripoff and canel it entirely strange
they didn't do that with ANS On A Bug's
Life okay can we
stop get me Cindy it sure looked like in
humans which features Marvel characters
who are kind of like mutants but also
kind of from space would be the next
massive onscreen team for Marvel
announced for a 2018 release the film
seemed to be built up from two entire
Seasons worth of story lines on ABC's
Marvel's Agents of Shield but then inh
humans was quietly dropped from the
schedule why there are a couple of
theories because of the disconnect
between Marvel's TV efforts and its
movie business Marvel Studios may not
have been happy at having the Inhumans
movies details dictated by a television
show with middling ratings meanwhile
rumor has it that in humans was the pet
project of Marvel CEO Ike pmut and when
po M was outed from his role at Marvel
Studios in favor of Studio president
Kevin fgi far dumped the film to stick
it to his rival and pursue his own
Vision instead namely Captain Marvel
Captain Marvel
herself Bri
arson although when you think about it
the biggest mistake of all might have
been Marvel selling the X-Men movie
rights to Fox way back in the 1990s
would never have had to hear about the
Inhumans movie in the first place in
2006 Fox Atomic began filming a modern
day reboot of the classic ' 80s College
movie series Revenge of the Nerds at
emeroy University in Atlanta and then
school officials actually read the
script here's actual footage from when
emeroy University's president finished
looking at the screenplay no anyway
after that the college immediately
pulled out of the project even though
much of the movie had already been
filmed producers were forced to complete
the movie at tiny Agnes Scott College
when Atomic honcho Peter rice saw
how rinky D the movie looked as a result
he decided to just scrap the entire
thing who made the bigger mistake emoy
for a green to participate in the movie
before reading the script or Fox for
actually caring about production values
and Revenge of the Nerds you know karate
no good in 2009 Terminator Salvation
earned $371 million worldwide thanks in
part to the star power of Christian Bale
as a time traveling robot killing
Humanity saving John Connor two sequels
were planned except the housian company
which produced the movie went bankrupt
even with all that Revenue through some
kind of financial idiocy they couldn't
pay off the $39 $9 million they owed the
hedge fund pacificore in order to pay
their debt hysan auctioned off the
rights to Terminator the winning bid
29.5 million from pacificore nice exit
strategy come with me if you want to
live here's a real what if way back in
1998 South Park creators Trey Parker and
Matt Stone signed a $1.5 million deal
with new line Cinema to write a prequel
to the 1994 hit comedy Dum and dummer it
sounds like a match made in heaven so
you're telling me there's a chance
so what was the idiot mistake turns out
Parker and stone didn't actually want to
do the project in the first place they
eventually gave the money back leading
new line to hire other writers for what
eventually turned out to be the
universally panned 2003 prequel dumb and
dumer when Harry met Lloyd hey I like
that movie Howard Stern first created
his superhero Alter Ego Fartman back in
1981 and it turned into a pre- internet
meme of a massively popular appearance
at the 1992 MTV Video Music Awards how
that feel Luke great great ass man yeah
it was such a hit that new line Cinema
started production on a feature film
called The Adventures of Fartman which
screenwriter JF laon promised would be
just as crude and lwd as you'd expect
from a Howard Stern movie however when
Executives got wind of what Lon was
planning they asked him to tone it down
and make it a mainstream PG-13 film
instead Stern immediately quit in
protest at the Dum request and that was
the end of fart man
[Music]
fart well comedian Sasha Baron Cohen was
once set to play the legendary lead
singer of Queen Freddy Mercury who died
in 1991 it seemed like the perfect fit
since Cohen is not only a big fan he
also Bears more than a passing
resemblance to Mercury but Cohen backed
out of the project when he discovered
that the surviving members of Queen
wanted the second half of the film to
focus not on Mercury but on how great
the band has continued to be since his
death8 years after Chevy Chase last
played smug and SMY reporter I am Fletch
in 1989's Fletch lives the franchise was
set to make a comeback thanks to
filmmaker Kevin Smith Smith wanted the
film to focus on fletch's daughter to be
played by his then girlfriend Jer Lauren
Adams but after Smith and Chase
squabbled over a plan to have Chase
reprises rolled as Fletch the entire
project was scrapped apparently Chase
had something better to do yeah I was
just passing through town and uh looking
for something to do this evening there
was nothing going on at The Rotary Club
I heard about this not to be deterred
Smith later convinced Miramax to buy the
rights to the franchise this time for an
origin prequel that would star his buddy
Jason Lee and wouldn't involve chase at
all but mirax didn't think Lee was a big
enough star and shut the whole thing
down looks like Chase had the last
[Laughter]
[Music]
laugh